The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK,
let me start again.
Thanks for helping
with Professor Rao
and working on the labs
the last two times.
I was saying the
labs were really
for his class,
which is 90 minutes,
so that we were kind of running
out of time just answering
those questions, getting the
system to say, OK, keep going.
Anyway, he's going
to develop those.
And I think they'll
be a good thing.
So actually, the second
lab, as I was watching it,
I was thinking of
a math question.
And may I report to you
on that math question?
So you remember the lab
was completing a matrix.
You got some entries.
And you can put in any other
entries in the other positions.
And the question was can you
complete it to a rank 1 matrix?
Here's my question.
What positions are OK?
And what positions
could you maybe not
be able to complete
to a rank 1 matrix?
Examples are the best.
So I'm looking at
this question here.
OK, I'm looking for a rank 1
matrix of the form x column y
transpose, or uv
transpose, I guess.
Those are the letters where
you used to, uv transpose.
And that means of course
that aij is ui times vj.
So we're able to choose--
we have m u's.
Let me ask a question.
Could I complete-- so let
me take m equal n equal 3.
So a 3 by 3 matrix.
I'm going to give you m
plus n minus 1, which is 3
plus 3 minus 1, five positions.
And suppose I give non-zeros
in which five positions?
So where is that number m
plus n minus 1 coming from?
Well, because I have
m u's and I have
n v's for a rank 1 matrix--
i goes from 1 to m,
j goes from 1 to n.
So I have m plus n.
But obviously I could require
the first u to be a 1.
In other words, when
I'm multiplying those,
there is one degree of freedom
that is sort of repeated here,
because if I'm just given--
anyway, you see it,
that I can rescale the u
so that the first u is a 1.
And that leave me
m plus n minus 1.
So could I give you
these five numbers
and could you complete
that to a rank 1 matrix?
So those are non-zeros.
Why do I say non-zeros?
Because if that number
happened to be a zero,
I'd have bad news there.
If I prescribed that one and
I prescribed it to be zero,
then if every column has to
be a multiple of that column,
these would all have to be 0.
So I don't want that.
I want to be able to
prescribe five numbers.
And therefore, they
better not be zero.
Could you complete the
job with that choice
of a five positions?
I think you could.
Because how would you
decide on that number?
Well, I mean at
least one way to look
at it is, what would
that number be there?
That number would be chosen.
There would be one and only
one choice for that that
would give rank 1.
In fact, that little 2 by 2
determinant would have to be?
0, right?
All the columns are supposed
to be multiples of one column.
All the rows are supposed
to be multiples of one row.
All the 2 by 2s are rank 1.
And rank 1 for a 2 by
2 means determinant 0.
So I would know what
that one had to be.
That number would have to be
a 1 2 times a 2 1 over a 1 1.
Every 2 by determinant
has to be 0 here.
If I want rank 1,
I can't stand any 2
by 2s that are
invertible matrices.
So all the determinants
have to be zero.
And, of course, then
these three numbers
would allow me to fill in there.
Those three numbers would
allow me to fill that.
Those three numbers will
It would be easy, easy.
So that I can see that those
are five positions that work.
Now, give me five
positions that won't work.
So this is good.
This is check.
Now, I want one where
I can't make it work.
So let me give that
number, that number.
So I'm looking for
something that fails,
a set of positions that fails.
And then I want to be able to
test, does the set of positions
work for any non-zeros
or does it not work?
What am I looking for here?
A different one that works?
OK, so what else would
work, apart from that?
Let's see, I suppose
I take that one.
Now, what about
that position there?
I must not choose
that one, right?
I must not choose that one,
because that would complete a 2
by 2.
And if I gave the wrong
numbers, the determinant
wouldn't be zero.
And I would be failed.
So I must not give
that position.
Maybe I could give
Maybe I could give this one.
How's that?
If I had those five, would
I be able to complete?
It looks good anyway.
It looks good.
Let's see, how would I
go about completing that?
Let's see, I would
know what that number
had to be from this 2 by 2.
From this 2 by 2, I
would know that number.
From this-- where now?
This and this and this,
no, that's not any good.
What do I do now?
How would I get this number?
Oh, OK, I guess I have to use--
this would complete that.
Oh, this 2 by 2, oh,
yeah, OK, no problem.
That would complete
that one, right?
But this one, I don't think
I can get immediately.
But I can get it.
Once I know these, then
obviously I can get that,
right?
So it's sort of nice
combinatorial problem.
Which five positions will work?
Which five will not work?
How do I tell?
Of course, that's for a 3 by 3.
Yeah, so let me--
I had like a bigger example.
Let me move up to 4 by 4.
So here comes the idea
that I learned last night
from a math professor
who does combinatorics.
So these people who
do combinatorics,
they know stuff that
the rest of us don't.
So his view is these would
be rows, one, two, three.
I may add another row.
Let me do a 4 by 4.
And these would be columns,
one, two, three, four.
Now, I'm looking for seven--
so if I prescribe an entry, I'll
put in an edge between them.
So let me let me hype
this one up to 4 by 4.
Here, a good one.
Actually, I'll just
draw this picture.
So suppose I prescribe
the 1, 1-- oh, yeah,
and over here I'll show
you what I've done.
So that I'm putting
in the 1, 1 position.
I'm looking for 7, right?
4 plus 4 minus 1, seven numbers.
OK.
Then, I'll put in,
this is row 2 column 1.
Row 2 column 1,
that would be there.
Then I'll put in a 2 to 4.
So that would be
row 2, column 4.
Then I'll put in a 3 to 4.
So that would be
row 3, column 4.
And finally, I'll put in--
let's see, so how
many have I done?
One, two, three, four,
and I've got to get up
to seven, prescribed seven.
Well, I'll put more in.
So on row 4, I gave 2, 3, and 4.
And did I put in this one?
Yes, I did.
So I've now prescribed
seven numbers.
Could I complete the
matrix to a rank 1 matrix?
You see the math question.
If I'm given seven
positions there--
this is another way to
look at the same picture.
This is I put in an
edge for every x.
So if I have seven x's,
I've got seven edges.
And this is called
a bipartite graph.
So it's a graph.
I've got four nodes
here, four nodes here.
So I have eight nodes.
It's a bipartite
graph because I have
one part of nodes over there,
one part of nodes here.
Bipartite means two parts.
So the rows give me
one part of the edges.
The columns give me the
other part of the edges.
And all the connections
go between the parts.
I don't have any lines
from a row to a row,
because the whole code is that
this tells me where those seven
positions are.
Now, I'm just going ask you,
can I complete the graph?
Can I complete the matrix?
Can I complete rank
1 matrix there?
What do you think?
And the real question
is, what's the rule?
How can I see when I
can't complete the matrix,
something gets in the way?
Here, what got in the
way was this 2 by 2.
And actually, I asked
the question on email,
can I always complete it--
yeah, so that would be
the question I could ask you.
Can I always
complete the graph--
complete the matrix to have rank
1 when I don't run into this?
Is that all I have
to avoid, a 2 by 2,
where I'm given all
four entries-- oh, yeah,
this I was able to complete.
Sorry to-- let's do one.
If I'm given those entries
and maybe some others,
I guess seven altogether,
that's a failure.
I can't prescribe any non-zeros
in those seven positions,
because if I prescribe
any non-zeros,
I probably won't have a
zero determinant here.
I won't have rank 1.
That column will not be a
multiple of that column.
Whatever I do here,
I've screwed up already.
So that's a fail.
Let me take that picture and
turn it into this picture, so
rows, columns.
So if I take these
seven, that's a row 1--
row 1, 2, 3, 4, so
row 1 goes to 1 and 2.
Row 2 goes to 1 and 2.
Row 3 goes to 4.
And row 4 goes to 3 and 4.
That's a failure.
And how do I know
it's a failure?
I want to now come
up with the answer.
So if I give any seven
positions or any m plus n
minus 1 positions like that, I
can create a graph like that,
just following the
rule that you saw.
Those seven positions gave
me seven edges in my graph.
And it's a bipartite
graph because every edge
goes from this part
over to this park.
And that's a failure.
And the reason it's a failure
is that I have here a cycle.
If I go across,
down, across, down, I
come back where I started.
That would be a
cycle equals failure.
Everybody see I can't give
these four numbers generally.
Once I've given you three,
I don't have any freedom
left with that fourth one.
And the way to see
that in this picture
is that there's a cycle.
So here is the
combinatorics thing
that Professor Postnikov
told me about last night.
You can complete to a
rank 1 matrix if and only
if no cycles.
So that just answered
my question perfectly.
This one is one where I can't
complete, and it's got a cycle.
A cycle meaning you come
back to where you started.
So my question to him was,
can you always complete it
if there are no 2
by 2s in the way?
And his answers told me that
maybe the 2 by 2s could be OK,
but there could be a
bigger cycle, a longer
cycle that would screw you up.
So let me close with an
example of that sort.
So this is going
to be fail again.
But no 2 by 2 is responsible.
In other words,
it's going to fail.
I won't be able to
complete this matrix,
even though there aren't
any completed 2 by 2s.
The 2 by 2, I knew
immediately was failure.
So let me see if I can do that.
So here's a failure.
This is rows 1, 2, 3, 4.
And this is columns 1, 2, 3, 4.
And I think I'm going
to have 1 given there.
And I sort of
started this before.
And 2 goes to 1 and 4.
And 3 goes to 4.
And 4 goes to--
let's see.
OK, now, I've only
put it in 2, 4, 5.
And I'm allowed seven.
But I think I'm already
in trouble here.
So let me draw this
picture for that.
So this is rows 1, 2, 3, 4.
And this is column 1, 2, 3, 4.
And now, I've
prescribed that one.
Oh, no, that goes from--
oh, I've forgotten the
right way to do the picture.
My bipartite graph wasn't
what it should have been.
So the 1, 2, 3, 4.
OK, now I'm going to do the
bipartite graph picture that
goes with this picture.
So 1 to 1.
2 to 1.
2 to 4.
But what I'm going to do--
let me just say what
I'm going to do.
I'm going to create a cycle
over here of length 6.
A cycle of length 4 is
what I got from a 2 by 2.
From my 2 by 2, that
took me one way, back
another, back
another, back another.
I completed a cycle.
I came back to where I
started with just four edges.
Now, I want to complete
a cycle with six edges.
So let me draw it
in the picture here.
Now, I'm going to put an
edge from 4 back to 1.
So 1 to 1, 1 to
4, 2 to 1, 2 to 4.
Have I got any--
I think 1, 2, ah, damn.
I didn't want a short cycle.
I want a bigger, longer cycle.
Let me get the darn thing here.
So 2 to 4 is not what I want.
So I start a cycle.
OK, go somewhere.
Go back.
Go somewhere.
Now, there I got it.
Length six.
So let me put the x's
in where they belong.
So 1 is connected to 1 and 4.
That's right.
2 is connected to 2 and 4.
3 is not connected to anybody.
Let's put that one in.
And 4 is connected to 1 and 2.
4 is connected to 1 and 2.
OK, I believe that picture
goes with that picture.
Now, my claim is
that there are no
there is no 2 by 2 in here that
shows me immediately failure.
But I will fail--
I can't live with those--
that looks like eight.
Sorry, I only want seven.
So shall I just take--
sorry?
AUDIENCE: You've got
3, 4 in the wrong spot.
GILBERT STRANG: 3, 4, and
it shouldn't be there.
All right, OK, thanks.
Right.
You see I'm not a
combinatorics person.
But it's so beautiful
to have the inspiration
to convert that
picture to this picture
and then realize that a
problem in this picture
is a cycle in this picture.
That's the whole message.
That's the whole message,
that when I'm looking here
a cycle means that I've
built in a requirement, which
random non-zeros won't satisfy.
So you see that anyway.
You see the cycle, 1,
2, 3, 4, 5, 6, yeah.
So there's a cycle there.
So somehow those six
x's, whichever they are--
I guess all but the 3 by 3.
So I could take away
this part of the graph
and just have 3 and 3, and there
would be 6 numbers in there
and that's too many.
OK, I'm going to stop
there exactly half way
through that class.
Well, I'm going to stop
there with a question, which
I don't know if I dare send
another question to Professor
Postnikov, who answered
this one perfectly.
But my question would
be, when could you
complete a rank 2 matrix?
What positions could you fill
in and be able to reach rank 2?
That would be trouble, right?
I don't know where we
would go with that.
But for us, for 18.065,
that's the natural question.
Rank 1 is super special for us.
And rank 2 or rank R
would be the general case.
So they're good math questions.
Now, topic 2, convolution.
So the first lab
in the course just
happened to have a convolution
and used that word and so on.
But we didn't connect
that with the lectures.
So now, I'd like to
talk about convolutions,
which are extremely important.
And they are
important in machine
learning because they give you
a set of weights connecting--
they're an efficient way to--
let me show you.
Let me show you.
So a convolution matrix--
and this will be a cyclic
convolution matrix.
And the shorthand for
cyclic convolution matrix
is circulant.
So what does a
circulant look like?
I'll call it C.
A circulant has
constant diagonals.
That's what convolution
means matrix wise.
Convolution means constant
down each diagonal.
And cyclic means complete,
circle around again.
The diagonals circle around.
So I'll just show
you what I mean.
So 4 by 4, let's say.
So it has some entry to--
there's one diagonal.
Here is another diagonal.
So now I have
constant diagonals.
But if it's going to
be a circulant matrix--
and this is the best family
of matrices in the world.
The algebra is just
terrific for these matrices.
And that's why they're the
heart of signal processing.
So this is a constant
diagonal matrix.
But it's not yet a circulant.
That diagonal circles
around to be completed.
Every diagonal has
four entries here.
So let me take
another one, say 1, 1.
Then that would
circle around to 1, 1.
And this guy could be 0.
There's a circulant matrix.
Do you understand
then what the entry--
you only need four numbers,
say the first column.
If you prescribe the first
column of a circulant matrix,
then you've told Matlab, for
example, all it needs to know.
If you tell it one column, it
can get all the other columns
just by cyclic shift.
There's the first
column, 2, 0, 1, 5.
The second column is 2, 0,
1, 5 shifted down by one.
The next column is again
shifted down by one, 2, 0, 1, 5.
And the last column
is 2, 0, 1, 5.
So they're all the same
columns after a cyclic shift.
So the key matrix in this is
really a cyclic shift matrix.
Say 0, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0-- so it
just has one non-zero diagonal.
And then it's cyclic.
Do you see that in
fact this matrix C,
I can produce this matrix
C from P and P squared?
What would P squared be?
And I'll write it here without
while keeping our eye on P.
So if I square that matrix,
what matrix would I get?
So this is a shift by one.
If I shift by one again, that's
multiplying it again by P.
So that would give me P squared.
What what's in the--
OK, so what happens now?
It's a shift by two I guess.
So this will be 0, 0, 1, 0.
This will be 0, 0, 0, 1.
Then it's cyclic still.
So I'll put in the 1s there
and then just fill in the 0s.
So P squared, shift by two.
You start out with this one.
Is that right?
Yes.
OK.
Yeah, let's just make
it multiply a vector,
x0, x1, x2, x3.
What it does is it puts--
well, I've started the
numbering with 2 here.
x2, x3, x0, and x1.
So it's shifted it by
two and cyclically.
So the x2, x3 that got
shifted off the bottom
come back to the top.
So the first property
is, of circulants--
so I suppose I have
matrices C and D circulants.
So fact 1, C times D
is also a circulant.
So if I multiply
circulant matrices,
I get more circulant matrices.
And the identity is
a circulant matrix.
I have a little group of
matrices, the best little group
of matrices there is.
I can multiply two
guys in the group,
and I get another
one in the group.
Why is CD also a circulant?
Let's see, can we see
why that fact is true?
I guess here here's
my way to look at it.
A circulant matrix--
let me put it here--
a circulant matrix, every
circulant matrix is C0 times
the identity circulant plus
C1 times the single shift
plus C2 times the double shift
plus C3 times the triple shift.
That's what it takes
to put C0, C1, C2,
and C3 on those diagonals.
C0I is obviously on
the main diagonal.
C1P-- remember what P is--
that puts C1 on
the next diagonal.
Then C2P squared, when I square
this, I've shifted by one more.
So it will put C2
on that diagonal.
And finally, C3 would
go in those positions.
So every circulant matrix
is a polynomial in P,
in a single shift.
This is any
combination of shifts.
This is a single shift.
That's a double shift.
That's a triple shift.
That's a zero shift.
And if I take combinations
I get a circulant matrix.
So now, I can see why
CD is also a circulant,
because this is a
polynomial in P.
And this is a polynomial
in P. And when
I multiply those together,
I get a polynomial in P.
But usually, if I multiply
a third degree polynomial
by another third
degree polynomial--
so say I'm looking at 4
by 4 circulant matrices--
so this would be a polynomial
of P in P third degree 3.
And this would be a
polynomial of degree 3.
So that would give me a
polynomial of degree 6.
But I don't want that.
That somehow I have to
define multiplication
so that I want
this to be degree--
these are all supposed
to be 4 by 4 matrices,
just like that one.
That's twice the identity
plus five P plus 1P squared
plus 0P cubed.
And suppose I square that.
Then, again, I'm going to
get up a circulant matrix.
And I don't want it
to go up to degree 7.
I just want four terms
in my polynomial.
I just want the main diagonal
and the next three diagonals
and then cycling around
completes the matrix.
So how to get degrees 3?
That's the question then.
Can you just tell me the answer?
So I'm multiplying-- yeah,
let's just do an example.
So I've C0, C1P, C2P squared,
C3P cubed times D0 plus D1P
plus D2P squared and D3P cubed.
So P is 4 by 4 circular shift.
And I'm writing the 4
by 4 matrix that way.
This should be the
identity, of course.
You knew that.
OK, so when I
multiply those guys,
why do I not get degree six?
Why is that product--
like P cubed times P
cubed C3P cubed times
DP3 cubed, that gives me
C3D3 P to the sixth power.
So what's up?
What do I do?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does P to the
4 equal to identity?
GILBERT STRANG:
Yes, that's the key.
That's the periodic part.
P to the 4 equal the identity.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So the P to the sixth term
is really a P squared term.
The P to the fifth term
is really a P term.
P the fourth term is really
a P to the zero term.
So I'm just doing cyclic
convolution actually.
Let me just say when
I'm multiplying--
yeah, so now, I'm
telling you what--
I can first tell you
what convolution is
and then what cyclic
convolution is.
And listen up to this, because
it's a good thing to know.
So, first of all, convolution.
So suppose I want to take
the convolution of 3, 1, 2--
that's often the symbol for
a convolution-- with 4, 6, 1.
So what does that mean?
I've got a vector.
So for me, what's hiding
there is polynomial 3
plus x plus 2x squared times
4 plus 6x plus 1x squared.
And I just multiply them out.
And I get 5--
so I get 3 times
4 gives me a 12.
3 times 6x is 18x.
But I've also got 4x from here.
So I've got 22x.
So I just do that multiplication
as of polynomials.
And what I'm doing is
convolution with the vectors.
And here's the way you
wrote it in first grade.
So here's first grade.
2, 12, 8.
You haven't learned
to carry yet.
So 12 goes in there as 12.
Then 1 is 4, 6, 1.
And 3 is 12, 18, 3.
And then you add up.
So you have 2, 13,
17, 22, and 12.
So that's the answer there.
That's the convolution--
I guess I have to take it from--
yeah-- 12.
3 times four gave 12.
Now, 3 times 6 plus 1
times 4 that's the 22.
Oh, yeah, we already
started here.
But now, what's after that 17?
Why did I say 17?
AUDIENCE: 8 plus 6 plus 3.
GILBERT STRANG: Oh,
8 plus 6 plus 3.
Thanks.
17.
And then 12 plus 1, 13.
And then 2.
That's non-cyclic.
So that's convolution.
Oh, if I want it
to be non-cyclic,
I don't put a circle in.
So that's a symbol for
ordinary convolution.
If you do the Matlab command
conv for convolution,
if you gave it those
vectors, it would give you
a vector with five
components as a result.
But now, let me make it cyclic.
So what's going to happen
now when I make it cyclic?
So this represents 12, 22P,
17P squared, 13P cubed.
And what's 13P cubed?
If n is 3 and I'm
doing 3 by 3 matrices,
then 13P cubed is the same as?
13, right?
P cube is I.
So the 13 will go back there.
And the 2 will be P fourth.
And it will go back as P.
So now with convolution,
cyclic convolution gives 12
and 13, 25, 22 and 2, 24,
and the 17.
So I'm getting back a vector of
length 3 just as I wanted to.
If I have a 3 by 3 matrix,
convolution cyclic circulant
matrix, with those three
diagonals and these three
diagonals, then I want
the answer to be a 3
by 3 matrix with
these diagonals.
So again, matrix multiplication
of circulant matrices
corresponds exactly to
multiplying polynomials
cyclically.
And that's cyclic convolution.
And then there's
just one little trick
to see if you've
got the numbers.
I believe that it should be true
that if 3 plus 1 plus 2 is 6,
4 plus 6 plus 1 is
11, and I believe
that those should add to what?
What do I hope that they add to?
66.
I'm a little nervous about
doing it, but I think we can.
Yeah, so 49, 59, 66, check.
Yeah, so the digits, the sum
of the digits of one factor
multiplies the sum of the
digits of the other factor
to give the sum of the
digits in the convolution.
And that would be
true whether we're
doing cyclic, which is bringing
the 13 and the 2 back in or not
cyclic, where we have 5 numbers.
That's actually a check that
I don't know if you ever
thought about that
in second grade,
multiplying these
numbers, multiplying
that number by that
number and getting
some answer, which probably half
the class did not get right.
Then fifth grade, they're
kind of getting it.
But if they knew a check, so
they could have just added
these numbers to get
11, added these numbers
to get 6, multiplied
those to get 66,
and check that
those added to 66.
That never occurred to me I
admit in second grade either.
But now you know.
Now you can pass second grade.
So this is the picture
for cyclic convolution.
And I just have a
few minutes left
to tell you about the
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of these matrices.
So what can you tell me
about the eigenvalues--
or say, the eigenvectors?
I have a matrix P. It happens
to be a permutation matrix.
But it's a matrix.
Then I take this
polynomial in the matrix.
What can you tell me about
eigenvectors of this matrix C?
So my C looks like that.
And I'm asking you for
the eigenvectors of that.
And I'm saying that that is a
polynomial, sum of powers of P,
like so.
In fact, the numbers here
just come off the diagonals.
So what about the eigenvectors?
AUDIENCE: All 1s.
GILBERT STRANG: Well,
that is an eigenvector.
That's true.
The vector of all 1s
will be an eigenvector.
With what eigenvalue actually?
AUDIENCE: C2 plus C1.
GILBERT STRANG: Yeah.
So what I want you to see
is the eigenvectors of C
are the same as the
eigenvectors of P.
If I have an
eigenvector of P, that's
also an eigenvector of P squared
and P cubed in a combination.
So eigenvectors of P
are eigenvectors of C.
So then the question is, what
are the eigenvectors of P?
You see what I mean?
It didn't really matter if
I'm looking for eigenvectors
what those numbers were.
The point is that those numbers
were constant on diagonals
and that therefore it's built
out of 1 matrix P, built out
of 1 matrix P. So all I have to
know is the eigenvectors of P.
So that's the final step here.
What are the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues of P?
So eigenvectors, eigenvalues
for P equal 1, 1, 1, and 1, say.
And otherwise zeros.
So somebody mentioned that
the vector of 1, 1, 1, 1, that
is an eigenvector, because
if I do that multiplication,
it shifts this vector down
and cyclically around.
But that just brings
back the same vector.
So lambda is 1.
And that's an eigenvector
with eigenvalue 1.
But this is a 4 by 4 matrix.
AUDIENCE: 1 minus 1, 1 minus 1.
GILBERT STRANG: Ah, now you're
guessing 1 minus 1, 1 minus 1.
Interesting.
Well, tell me an
eigenvector for minus 1.
Do you want to just
alternate signs there?
So let me let me do that
multiplication times 1 minus 1,
1 minus 1.
Of course, I don't have
to do that multiplication.
I'm just going to shift this.
So I'm going to shift
that down, 1 minus 1
and cyclically around.
And now, what's the eigenvalue?
It is an eigenvector.
And what multiple of that
vector gives that vector?
AUDIENCE: Minus 1.
GILBERT STRANG: Minus 1.
So that was a good idea.
But the rest of what
you said was a bad idea,
because the next eigenvectors
got to be somewhere else.
We've just got one eigenvalue
there and one there.
And we haven't
got the other two.
So what are the
other two eigenvalues
of this permutation matrix?
AUDIENCE: 1.
GILBERT STRANG: 1, that's right.
We're in a circulant world.
Draw a circle.
So the eigenvectors are
the four roots of 1.
Complex.
So 1 and minus 1 you've got.
These are the lambdas.
But the other ones are
I and minus I. Yeah.
Yeah.
Why don't I, since
time's up, let me
leave until Friday
the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors for in
general, for arbitrary size.
But that's a picture
of the eigen--
we're close to the eigenvectors
and eigenvalues of every--
all circulants have
the same eigenvectors.
All circulants have that
eigenvector, 4 by 4.
All circulants have
that eigenvector 4 by 4.
And we'll find the other two.
OK, so I'll see you Friday
for those and the convolution
rule, which is the most
important rule in signal
processing.
OK.
Thanks.